[Music]
my name is Barry seal that's for the
damage for your sister
hey little darling and you're back and
somebody's really happened you never saw
me copy your class miss Civil Air Patrol
pile like you shouldn't be flying busted
by a baker
haven't you ever wanted something more
Barry you should be serving your country
Lucy hey
[Music]
we need you to deliver stuff for us oh
this is legal if you're doing ups are
the good guys
very seals it goddamn genius you were an
airline pilot berry that's how you
support this family is it gonna be good
for us trust me
Roscoe dug this up in the backyard there
Bill's blown around everywhere I'll rake
it up in the morning don't know and
caddies have more trunk space than any
other car I'll get each and every one of
you the cat in your troubles I'm gonna
walk out of here
I read a damn thing any wonder you can
do about it
boy should have taken a cat
I was working for the CIA a DEA and
Pablo Escobar leukemia and toss kilos
that's 1500 kilo part in one go get it
done
[Music]
[Music]